[Music]
there is a danger when a show becomes
it's happened a lot i'm a tv buff i've
been watching television as a kid and i
really watch it critically and it's one
of the things i i'm so fascinated with
your show is that i just never i'm
always looking for the flaw and i can't
find it that's me as a viewer but i i'm
curious when you when you look at that
show and you see a lot of shows when
they get successful they lose their way
and you start hearing about famous
people who would like to be in the show
as a cameo and it can be tempting you
know have you had famous people or have
it gotten back to you that there are
certain people that are fans and there's
ever a pressure like i'd like to write
that person into the show well man you
know you'd love to write in every all
your you know all your heroes and
whatnot are we here i i have no proof of
this but anecdotally i hear through the
grapevine that keith richards is a fan
right i would love
that would be that would be pretty cool
he would fit in somewhere yeah
right
yes he
[Laughter]
i
would
know that's up to you guys to figure out
how
if you put him in it should be the exact
opposite of what you would think yeah
he's the real square dad
what's going on here
what is this i don't know i'm doing a
chimney sweep again
dick van dyke
yeah yeah
yeah
um
do you know
do you know like
everybody uh you know andy's a huge fan
we will all watch the episodes and then
we come in and we talk about where is
this going where is this going
obviously we don't want any spoilers but
do you know where you're going having a
clue do you have a clue now we we we do
tend to write ourselves into corners uh
and uh we get very nervous when that
happens but we uh at that point we just
walter white uh has this amazing ability
to get himself out of some very tight
states
that is the result of seven people uh of
of of at least average intelligence
working many many hours many many weeks
straight you know trying to get him out
of these jams we could never do it what
he does right coming up with this stuff
instantly but uh yeah we have written
ourselves in a couple of corners and and
gotten very fearful that we'd have to go
back and tear apart the stuff we had
written uh prior to that moment but so
far
knocking wood so far we're uh we have
pulled pulled it out of the fire on a
couple of occasions yeah you've done
more than that we have a uh we have a
clip here speaking of walter white i
think this is a scene
where he's uh he's got a very tense
obvious relationship with his wife and
it's gotten ten more and more tense more
and more tense and it really looked like
they were done for a while and he's
really forcing this relationship with
skyler his wife
back
into at least they're cohabitating now
they're living together so let's take a
look at this clip i like setting up your
clips from breaking bad
i'm not your wife
and you're hostage
but
since you insist on keeping me
imprisoned i'll make you a deal i will
launder your money
i'll keep your secrets
but the kids will stay at hank and
maurice they have a chance of being safe
like you've seen too many movies
our children are not
in danger
just a couple of days ago
you told me that a man held a gun to
your head you said it like it was a
point
of pride there's nothing you can say
that'll convince me there won't come a
day that somebody will knock on that
door looking to harm you or me or all of
us
and when that day comes
the children cannot be here
you agree to that
and i will be whatever kind of partner
you want me to be
that is right out of my marriage
i'm sorry
you captured my marriage perfectly
you're staying i'll stay let the
children go